well it's like finding five bucks in
your jacket pocket that you forgot about
but in some cases it could be to the
tune of thousands we're talking about
unclaimed property just waiting for you
as Heather Mills reports it was a
Lifeline for one woman who like many
others was out of work in the height of
the pandemic
no it's not the lotto no ticket required
but it sure felt like a windfall to
Stacy Miller Eisenberg honestly I was in
shock it was 2020 the Nevada Department
of Employment training and
Rehabilitation or Dieter was stretched
then problems plagued the system and
unemployment claims were skyrocketing it
was one of those Rock Bottom times for
everybody Eisenberg and her husband both
out of work but then a simple search
online and finally relief it was really
a godsend at a time when when we really
needed that money her money just waiting
to be collected I did a double take and
a triple take and then walked into my
husband and said what did you get done
today because I just found seven
thousand dollars
so as of today we have more than one
billion dollars worth of money for
nevadans money that's sitting in the
state's unclaimed property division that
just never found its way into your
pocket either because of misspellings on
a check or address changes or even named
changes but Nevada state treasurer Zach
co9 says when new and corrected data
began streaming in from Dieter his
Department was ultimately able to return
two million bucks to folks who'd lost
their job by sending letters to those
people individuals who we know needed
that money people like Eisenberg I was
grateful to have it and you know I mean
it was mortgage payments and car
payments and you know things to just
help keep you afloat during what's been
a really rough couple of years for
everyone well her money was listed under
her maiden name maybe you're next it is
so simple I'll walk you through it
you're going to go to
claimitnevada.org simply just click on
this button search your name here we'll
look up me Heather Mills
okay that one oh that's not me but you
could search other names too search
everybody you know search your neighbors
it's a great thing to say Hey you know
by the bye uh thanks for picking up my
newspaper I found a couple of thousand
dollars for you while much of the
unclaimed property sits unidentified
Conan says they were eventually able to
cut through the government red tape and
ultimately changed a law that now
enables the treasurer to seek out people
who are owed money there is still a lot
sitting in the Coffer you never know
what's there you should just I I urge
everybody to go check it Heather Mills
eight news now the unclaimed property
division also includes material items
items left in safety deposit boxes and
the like and for those the state has an
annual auction and the money collected
from the sale goes into the individual's
account until he or she claims it